- So, welcome everybody
to, I think it's DVT 3.6,
where we're gonna be talking about
customizing Llama models for code.
If that's a session you expect to be in,
that's the session you're at.
If it's not, then hopefully
you're able to find
the other one you wanna be
at. Otherwise, stick around.
My name's Eissa Jamil.
I'm a AI partner engineer at Meta,
and hopefully this is informative
and helpful for everybody.
Thanks also for just showing up
and being ready to learn, hopefully.
So, for today's agenda, we'll
be going over basically ways
to empower developers to
basically build with Llama
using basically tools that we have
that'll help you enhance
coding capabilities
for productivity use cases,
and all of those types of things.
Hopefully some takeaways
you'll get from this session
include learning basically the challenges
you're gonna face when adapting
LLAMs for coding tasks,
understanding data prep,
model training, and evals,
and then also discovering
Llama deployment strategies
on AWS, whether it be
Bedrock, SageMaker, EKS,
even EC2, whatever you end
up doing for your use cases,
and hopefully we'll explore a little bit
into real-world use cases
as we progress here.
So, before we kick into things,
we do have a pre-presentation
anonymous survey.
If you guys have a
minute to scan the code,
I'll keep the slide up.
It takes five seconds to complete.
We'd super appreciate it.
So, I'll go ahead and just
be quiet for a minute.
All right.
So, let's go ahead and jump in.
We're gonna start with a little bit
of an introduction to Llama.
Most of you probably have already
messed around with Llama,
played, deployed it.
Nevertheless, we'll do a
little bit of an introduction,
tell you a little bit
of a background story
on the progression of Llama,
and then we'll dive in a little bit more
into some of the
technicalities and challenges
you'll face when fine-tuning
for coding tasks,
and then at the end, we'll go
through a couple of example,
basically notebooks, which are
from our Llama Recipes repo
where we publish end-to-end use cases,
examples, stuff like that.
But yeah, we'll go ahead
and just jump on in here.
So, looking at this slide,
Llama's really, the idea
behind it is it's open source.
It's a great foundation to really unlock
any sort of use cases
you're trying to build for.
We see a lot of organizations building,
like we have the examples
here for language translation,
use cases, personal assistants, chatbots,
agents, content creation.
It's a wide gamut of topics and use cases,
and that's something which
we are super excited to see
the last few years with
Llama 2 release, Llama 3,
and even Llama 4 as it's released.
We love hearing about
what people are doing,
and that's just kind
of a high level there.
So, talking about a little
bit of the history of Llama,
it's crazy to think Llama 1 came out
just a couple of years ago.
Early February, Llama 1 came
out, research purpose mainly.
We then came out later
that year with Llama 2
with the ability to use it
for commercial use cases.
And later on that year, we had Code Llama.
We released Purple Llama,
kind of built around safety
and content moderation,
input/output filtering.
And you can see the family of
models just kept on evolving.
We had Llama 3 release.
That came with a number of awesome models.
In particular, everybody
loved Llama 3.1, 8B.
And then we had 3.2, which introduced
some multimodal models,
so you had the ability
to do input with text or image.
And then you also had our small models.
If you were using anything
that really needed
fast inference or you wanted really small,
basically ability to deploy a small model,
we released a 1B and a
3B model at that time.
We also released Llama
Stack, basically a framework
for building with Llama, and
then we released Llama 3.3.
That's where we released
an updated version of 70B,
which was a great model all around.
And then in 2025, we released Llama 4,
which came with Scout and Maverick.
So these stats aren't
completely up to date,
but just from earlier this year,
I think this aligns with when
we had our LlamaCon event,
we had over a billion
Hugging Face downloads,
which is amazing for us
to see how many people
are interacting and
actually trying to build
with our models, and that's
what our intention is.
And over 200,000 derivative models existed
at that time that we could see.
And that was mainly from
checking Hugging Face
and the access we could see ourselves.
We don't know what
everybody else is building.
We don't know what's
being deployed in private
or being developed within VPCs.
So this is just data we had at the time.
So it's amazing to see.
And just in general, I
mean, open source is huge.
It's a great area we're very
much always gung-ho about.
It allows for deployment flexibility.
If you wanna go on-prem, you
wanna go within your own VPC,
you wanna go however you
want, it's an option.
You can fine-tune the models,
take 'em, do whatever you want, customize,
all of that good stuff.
And then there's the model
distillation capabilities
where whether you're using
something like Llama 3.370B
or you go over to something like 405B,
all of those give you great options to go
and look at options for distillation.
So just diving in a little bit more
into exploring that family of models.
You can see here, I talked
a little bit about 3.18B,
and I just mentioned 405B.
You could see some recommendations here
for when you would use
them versus other times.
8B has become a super powerful
model for customization.
It's fast to fine-tune, it's
relatively cost-effective,
and it runs fast.
A lot of you have customers
or your company in general
is engaging in a solution that needs
to be able to do quick inference,
and you don't really need
to be running a 70B model.
You might just fine-tune
8B and run with that.
We also talked about 70B.
Performance, super good on that one.
You're able to go customize
that model as well,
and you're seeing a lot of
conversational-type stuff,
a lot of deep context-type
use cases being built there.
And then we had Llama 4 earlier this year.
This was when we released
our first two big multimodal models.
Again, image and text input, text output.
And they allowed for the first time,
our multimodal models allowing multi-image
to be really capable.
And Scout and Maverick were just
two different size parameter models
with slightly different
capabilities and context lengths.
If you wanted 10 million context length,
you could have gone with Scout.
If you wanted something like Maverick,
it would have a slightly
less context length on it.
So let's talk about how can
you actually use these models?
How can you go and deploy
and build for your solutions?
So one of the ways that
you can do it is via AWS.
We're all here for reInvent.
Everybody, I assume, knows some of this.
But just in case, I'll go ahead
and just kinda talk a
little bit about this.
So we have Amazon Bedrock here at the top.
And with Bedrock, you've
got the ability to go
build solutions quickly using
just a model-as-a-service,
hosted API endpoint, right?
You're not gonna run any infrastructure.
You're not gonna handle
any of the deployment.
You have some options to go
and customize a little bit.
But really, you're just
getting an endpoint
and you're sending in your
prompts and getting output.
There's a bunch of features
built in, relatively hands-off.
You don't have to go build that yourself.
So you don't have to
orchestrate as much yourself.
That's the idea there.
All of the Llama models
have been on Bedrock
for the most part, except for 1B and 3B.
And I think the main models
that I'm seeing people
use right now, 8B, 70B, those models
are definitely available on Bedrock.
So that's your fast get-up-and-go.
You wanna prototype, go build.
Don't worry about it.
A lot of times you see people,
when they wanna go to production,
you're looking for more
throughput, lower latency.
Maybe that's when you progress
to using something like SageMaker, right?
And you can go to using the
actual optimized chipsets,
whether it be in French here or Trainium.
Or if you're gonna go and
you wanna deploy on GPU,
then you can go SageMaker, you can go EKS.
You can even do EC2 if you
know how to manage everything.
But those are also really
powerful in general.
When you're thinking about SageMaker,
if you're gonna go into fine-tuning,
if you're gonna do clusters,
there's options there,
like HyperPod to go ahead and
do a lot of that management
without you having to think about it.
All right, so progressing on a
little bit more now on Llama.
So with Llama, something
that we did this year
is we began releasing
tools to help you build.
And the reason I'm talking about this
when we're in a session about fine-tuning
for coding use cases is
because a lot of people
are looking at moving from other models
or from older Llama
models to newer models.
And one of the tools that we developed
was basically Llama PromptOps.
It's a way for you to go
and automatically optimize
your prompts for the Llama models.
It says you're optimizing
prompts for Llama models,
and it doesn't say you
have to be on a Llama model
to optimize for Llama.
If you're coming from another model,
that is an option you can go
and utilize in your workstream.
It's just a simple Python package,
pretty lightweight to run,
but you do have to download,
deploy, and manage that
yourself at this time.
So some of the benefits
there are listed above.
I mean, you can imagine
less trial and error.
You're not gonna be manually
telling your data science team
or some prompt engineer folks to go
and manually tweak your
prompts to make it work.
Instead, you can go take
your entire data set,
all your prompts, throw 'em through this,
and have that conversion
happen for you, right?
Helps accelerate optimizations.
You get data-driven
improvement-type learning from this.
So a lot of benefits overall.
And you can kinda see a little bit
about how the actual workflow is set up.
Pretty simple, straightforward.
But this is one of the things
that we kicked off this year
as a tool in addition to a few others,
which we'll mention a little later.
So now let's dive into customizing
the actual Llama models.
And the idea here being, let's
think about customization,
customization for coding tasks
when we're trying to go
and train for that, right?
So the Llama models as they are
can do some coding
capabilities within them
if you're just using the general models.
It's not necessarily the best.
It's not what you're gonna be wanting
for very specific use cases.
And with specific languages,
you're gonna probably need
to do a lot more fine-tuning
and customization work to ensure
it's working for what you need.
So let's talk about, actually
before I move forward, yeah.
Let's go ahead and talk
about some of the reasons
why adapting the LLAMs in general,
not just Llama, is challenging.
So we all probably have worked
with programming languages before.
They all have different syntaxes
depending on which versions
you're using, things change.
That creates a lot of complication.
Models can get it.
If you use something like CodeLlama,
then it did a pretty good
job at figuring this out
with the main languages it was trained on.
But there's a lot of complication
behind recognizing and generating code
that really adheres to
a specific language.
Next, data quality.
We all know if you're training models,
datasets are super important.
And we're in a completely
different world right now
than we were even a year ago
with regards to datasets
that are available,
datasets you can purchase,
datasets that you are curating yourself
from your internal actual data.
Completely different capability of tools
are available to you.
And that is still a very
challenging thing for coding.
And the reason for that is
coding datasets are generally smaller.
They're a little harder to come by.
They are becoming a lot more available.
You're finding a lot of
stuff available open source,
which is great, but then
that doesn't really tailor
specifically to what you need
or your specific company's
standards, right?
And everybody has those.
So that's an extremely
difficult and challenging task
when you're thinking about coding as well.
And then evaluations.
Evals, I think, have
been a pretty hot topic
'cause everybody went
the last couple of years
from experimenting and
prototyping to figuring out,
okay, these are cool applications
we developed with LLMs,
but now we wanna go to production.
How do we ensure this is actually working
and how do we ensure we're
able to properly validate
and eval these things?
Coding, assessing it is complicated.
It's just not straightforward
to your code base,
kind of like datasets aren't
straightforward always with it,
and there's not a lot out there.
So just some challenges
to talk about there.
So let's think about how to
get started with LLM models
if you're thinking about fine-tuning here.
Really high-level steps,
but this is just kind of a
little flow you would imagine
as you're thinking about
any sort of fine-tuning
you're gonna do, not only coding, right?
So in any sort of fine-tuning
you're gonna be doing,
you're going to be doing
that data ingestion.
You've gotta go ahead
and get your data set up
so you can actually do
that fine-tuning pass
or whatever training you're doing.
So you're gonna be looking at
code and programming resources,
your internal datasets,
your internal code repos.
That's all gonna be raw data to an extent
unless you can find stuff that's curated
and already pre-processed.
So the next thing you're gonna go into
is that step of preparing
that code by pre-processing,
cleaning it up, ensuring you don't have,
let's imagine comments and a whole bunch
of really custom flares sitting in code,
which can exist depending
on your engineers,
depending on the teams,
depending on the resources
that you're actually
downloading this from.
You go into optimizing that code,
optimizing that for code
generation tasks and training,
right, and you're looking
at how do I set this up
in a way which you've got a dataset now
from all this code and the
resources you've developed,
you've pre-processed, and
you're ensuring it's set up
in a way that can begin helping
with your actual training passes.
And then you're gonna go
through your eval steps.
You're gonna ensure that the
quality, all of that stuff,
from a high-level standpoint.
Then you go into your deployment.
So super high-level steps,
this kind of a workflow
that you're gonna run through.
So let's talk a little
bit about data prep.
And some of these slides
here will have a little bit
of duplication between them
because during these initial
stages where you're
setting up for fine-tuning
and doing your training passes,
a lot of times you're gonna be
doing iteration on your data
and you're gonna be figuring
out how to structure things
in better ways and then how to optimize
your configuration for
training, all of that.
So when we think about data prep,
really what you're doing
is you're organizing
and putting together your code datasets
so you can begin processing,
the first step always.
You're gonna be processing
all your datasets
or basically acquiring it and then going
and setting up the pre-processing
and then going into the training.
So then we talk about,
you've now acquired the data,
now we've gotta actually process this
and do some cleaning, right?
So what do you end up doing in this?
You're gonna go in and you need to refine
and secure your code for
whatever your use case is.
Whether it be as a coding assistant
that you're gonna have running
or you have something
specific to mainframes
or let's say low-resource languages
or low-resource coding tasks,
those are all gonna be opportunities there
for you to possibly be setting
your actual training material up for.
And that might include kind
of a handful of these tasks.
Again, this is a pretty
high-level run-through
of the things you're
gonna need to consider,
but you might have to go and segment
and filter the code by language.
You're gonna probably
have multiple languages
in your repos, all of that good stuff.
So you're gonna go and set that up,
make sure that things are
properly pre-processed
and filtered out by languages
and different versionings.
You're gonna sanitize things.
All of our repos probably
have some sort of
sensitive data or information
that may need to get stripped.
You wanna go and make sure
that's been taken care of.
You're gonna begin
looking at tokenization.
Do you have proper tokenization?
Do you have to have custom tokenizer?
Is there something
there that is gonna work
for your data set?
You're gonna have to
iterate on that a few times.
Then we're moving into basically ensuring
if you have anything that
is privacy-sensitive,
you've gotta go and kind
of ensure the transforms
and the transformations
that are sitting there
are properly occurring.
And that's gonna require
a little bit of review.
So you do your pre-processing and cleaning
of your data sets, kind
of iterate from there.
So super simple, a little example here.
I won't even read through this,
but just a way to go ahead
and do some code cleanup.
Very simple.
Then let's go into a little
bit of tokenization again.
Just some really simple
snippets here, just as examples.
A lot of this is a lot more descriptive
if you go into Llama Recipes
and you look at a lot of our fine-tuning
or end-to-end use case examples.
But I figured I'm not gonna
walk through it line by line,
so let's keep it simple here.
So let's talk about the
actual fine-tuning situation.
So you've gone, you've got your,
you've aggregated the data,
you've gone and cleaned
it up and processed.
Now you're actually
getting to fine-tuning.
Fine-tuning is not a
one-pass-and-done type of thing.
A lot of times you're doing
several loops of fine-tuning.
You're gonna go, you're gonna iterate,
you're gonna look at what
your loss values are,
the quality looks like,
you're gonna eval things,
and you're gonna determine, do
you need to adjust datasets?
Do you need to adjust parameters?
It's a involved process.
And when you think about
optimizing code generation
as a particular kind of example here,
we've got some tips here for
how you would think about it.
So if you're looking to do it
and you're looking to
fine-tune a specific model,
8B is still a model that people
are trying to use, right?
8B's very, it's relatively lean.
It works pretty well, it's fast,
and it can solve a lot
of specific problems
if you go and customize the model.
70B has a lot more capability.
A lot of people will start there.
When you're thinking about
which model to choose,
you'll start at 70B or
something like that,
and then if it works well,
they'll look at how do we
maybe compress that down
to an 8B model just to save, right?
So then you'll, as you're
running your fine-tuning passes,
you start thinking about
getting this running,
you're gonna think about
how do you actually
implement this fine-tuning
and how do you run this
in a efficient way?
So you'll look at
different SFT techniques,
so supervised fine-tuning.
You'll look at am I going to
run basically full parameter?
Am I gonna run something compressed?
It's totally up to you,
and a lot of people will
try to go on like Peft
or LoRa or something like that,
and that's what they're gonna do in first,
and then they're gonna
kind of evolve from there.
You're gonna look at nowadays RL,
which is a pretty hot topic,
but in general, RL's a
pretty well-known thing.
People have been doing
RLHF for many, many years.
That's definitely a way to
improve your actual fine-tuning
and optimize your actual process here,
and then you're gonna look at can,
do I wanna actually run
and manage all this stuff
or do I wanna use tools that are available
that can automate and build
out a lot of this process
for me, and that's where I
have the bullet point there,
the check mark around SageMaker.
That's just an option for you to go
and use a robust training infrastructure
with the tools and all the
actual features built in,
so you don't have to go and orchestrate
this fine-tuning pipeline and
all the iterations manually.
You can just use that.
You also have the ability
to go to like Hyperpod,
and if you need to do
distributed-type training,
EKS, and all of that.
So pushing on, just a super easy example
of what you're gonna look
at if you're gonna set up
an actual run of fine-tuning here.
You're gonna go ahead and set up the code,
set up the configuration parameters,
and then let it run, right?
This is an example running through Epochs.
That doesn't mean much,
depending on your use case.
You're gonna go ahead and
have to iterate on that
or figure out what's
worked for you guys before,
look at what your learning
rates are, loss rates,
all of that, understand, am I
getting the progress we want?
Is this eval-ing?
You're gonna pick,
obviously, instance types.
So that's a GPU.
Many of us were probably using,
I think that's the A100s.
So a lot of times you're gonna either pick
with the larger Llama models,
you're gonna be running like a P4D, a P5,
something like that.
You could also use Trainium for this.
It is supported, and those
are all options there.
So eval, next big topic.
Evaluation is super critical.
As you're going to do fine-tuning,
as you're gonna be looking
at, did this actually work?
Is this something that's
sufficient for my customer's needs?
You're probably gonna
have an eval data set
or you're gonna have to generate one
for evaluating and validating
that your fine-tuned model is
performing like you wanted.
So you're gonna have to set
up basically a reliable way
for you to determine, is my
code generation now improved
after I've done my fine-tuning?
That's gonna help inform you,
did my training data set help?
Did my configuration parameters help?
Do I need to run more epochs?
Do I need to change and pivot things?
I'd say at least when I
run through training loops,
it's more so gonna be at
least five or more passes
on my fine-tuning, and that's
gonna lead me towards the,
let's say the eval metrics that I want,
but that's 100% dependent on you
and what sort of data sets that you have
when you go into this.
So that's one of the
reasons we really emphasize
data sets are super critical
when you're going into this,
having a really well-established one,
one that's really well-formed,
is going to help ideally
reduce a lot of the complexity
and passes you'll have to run,
but again, that's not
necessarily guaranteed.
Oops.
So let's just continue through this slide.
So I mentioned things,
but let's look at the bullet points here.
So you're gonna want, with
evals, understand key metrics,
so your customers are gonna have key needs
they want to perform at a certain level
of accuracy and confidence.
That's gonna be one thing.
When their coders are
using a coding assistant
or a code generation,
you're gonna wanna make sure that works.
You're gonna wanna make sure
it's creating compilable code.
it's doing stuff contextually aware.
So that's gonna be something
you need to build into your evals.
That also includes things like human eval
and custom internal datasets.
You're gonna have, ideally,
ways to monitor the
evaluations continuously
and run these things post-deployment.
And then there's gonna
be generalized metrics
that you can also kind of depend on,
like blue or any other
kind of standardized ones
that are out there.
So let's think about deployment now.
So you've gone, you've decided
to customize the model,
you've gone through your pre-processing,
you've fine-tuned, you decide,
this version, this
customized model weights
are ready to go and deploy.
Maybe they're not perfect, maybe they are.
You're gonna go deploy it.
A lot of options to deploy.
We've mentioned them already.
Bedrock allows for managed inference,
but also allows for custom model import,
which you can take advantage of,
especially when you're prototyping
or doing a lot of these loops
and you don't wanna go set
up all the infrastructure
and manage that too.
That's an option.
We have things like EKS.
A lot of people, when they
decide to go into production
or if you have a mature organization
that knows how to manage infrastructure,
you're looking at options like EKS
for custom kind of deployment
of model weights, right?
And then you have other
considerations with code in general.
So now you're looking at,
you're not just deploying to an endpoint
and allowing people to prompt it.
You're looking at integrations with IDEs.
You're looking at, does
this go into VS Code?
Does it go into my other IDEs
that are available to my engineers?
Does it go into a web client?
A lot of options there.
Then a lot of open questions on
how does that actually go
through our repo updates
or our source control
and versioning updates?
Do we have to keep custom
parameters in there
that state where code is being generated
versus being manually edited?
A lot of considerations there.
You're also looking at deployment.
Okay, are you gonna be setting
up custom REST APIs for this?
And then you're gonna be
looking at code review bots.
How do those integrate with things?
A lot of us see that
within our organizations
where you have code review bots
and basically automated systems
to help catch these things,
catch errors, catch issues before they hit
even like a alpha train
or something like that
or before it goes into
any deployment passes.
But all of these are things
you're gonna be considering
as you're thinking about deployment.
So deployment and just another
example here using FastAPI.
I won't necessarily go through this,
but just another option
as you're looking at
basic quick deployment options
and quick deployment capabilities.
There's a lot of options like this too,
but I thought I'd just put up an example.
So I spoke a lot in that
past 25, 30 minutes.
Best practices for deploying Llama models.
Let's ensure that data is available
is basically deduped, cleaned up,
pre-processed before training.
In general, they're open source models.
We like to really create
an open community.
We love the idea of contributing
back as you've learned,
maybe not obviously datasets.
A lot of that has information
that's confidential or private.
We understand that.
That's the power of open source models.
You can train for your own
purposes and use cases,
but then contributing back is a big thing.
Basically optimizing inference costs
by picking the right models
is always a critical thing.
You look to train a model.
You maybe don't wanna be running 70B
unless it's a complex task.
So you look at how do you minimize that?
You look at an option with 8B.
That's why we have so many
models that we've made available.
It gives you that
customization capability,
the ability to choose what you want,
how much you wanna spend
and what sort of
performance you're getting.
And then just in general,
when you're looking at
working with Llama models,
engage with the open source
community, engage with us.
We do obviously look to
developers for feedback
and to continue growing
the Llama community
and also effectively create
better models in the future.
Now, let's think about real world examples
for just a minute.
So real world examples on the code side,
you're looking at internal tools.
You're looking to basically
accelerate development,
boost productivity.
That's a big reasoning we're using LLMs
and that's why we're getting
these assessments developed.
Automated code reviews, huge use case.
A lot of this stuff is happening.
Anytime somebody submits
a diff and that gets PR'd,
those types of things are
going through code reviews.
Even when a diff gets submit,
code reviews kick off.
All of those things take
time, they take money,
they take compute in order
to run and accelerate.
Not all of that's running, obviously,
via humans being tied in.
It's all automated.
There's a lot of old
ML ways of doing that.
Now, LLMs are coming in and
they're helping to use NLP
to be able to do that type of thing too.
And it works very well,
especially when you customize your model
and you orchestrate multi-models
for those use cases.
And then just streamlining DevOps.
So you're talking about customizing models
and basically being able to use agents
for the same purposes,
but then allowing orchestration
of multiple tasks.
If you're looking at orchestrating agents
to go and do your fine
tuning from end to end
or thinking about data processing,
those are all options
that people are looking
when they're customizing
something like Llama
for coding tasks.
So I'm gonna transition to not necessarily
a walkthrough or demo, but
a couple of examples here.
So what I wanted to show everybody
were a couple of examples
where we have basically
built coding assistants
and we've published these
on our open source Llama recipes repo
or Llama cookbooks I believe
is what we've named it now.
And the idea behind them is
these are either getting
started type examples,
they're full end to end POCs
or just use case solutions
for anybody to take
and then use as a frame of reference
for building your own
kind of clone of that.
Or we actually have some
end to end applications
and solutions we've built here
which we also publish in open source.
So I wanted to go through in particular
just a quick run of this example we have
where basically we've built
with a coding assistant
and what we've done is we've gone through
a few different tasks
where we wanted to migrate
basically an open AI API to Llama API.
We went through fine tuning Llama models.
We built a rag chat bot with Llama
and then we did some upgrades
'cause for this particular example
we had originally built it with Llama 3
and then we wanted to migrate to Llama 4.
So it's a mixture of steps here
not necessarily solving
an exact coding use case
but in general this is the process
you're gonna look at when you're running
a similar use case like a
coding assistant, right?
So in the first stage here
we go through some examples
basically migrating an
open AI API to Llama.
We've kind of showed you guys
how we thought about this.
This is something which easily
gets kind of transferred
if you go into using prompt
ops as an opportunity here.
You can go and use that
to really streamline this.
Next what we do is we go
into fine tuning Llama models
and we talk here about how
we go through that process.
All the code is available on this as well
if you just go up a level and
that's gonna be an example.
We talk about actually
building that rag chat bot
with the fine-tuned model
and then we talk about
how you think about going
from Llama 3 to Llama 4.
Again, a perfect example
use case of prompt ops.
So another one I wanted
to kind of share here
was generating code-based
docs because it's related to
if we're looking at coding assistants
or we're looking at
customizing models for code
this is a very common use case
where we've built an example here
of being able to use
Llama to go and build out
useful generation of docs.
And this is something you
can go ahead and build out
kind of run on a small server
or run on a small endpoint
and then go ahead and go
through your entire code base
to begin documenting everything.
I won't run through every step of this,
but again, these are just
examples I wanted to share
to show exactly end-to-end
like a lot of the tools
and the capabilities that
we've already gone and built
and we're trying to make accessible.
So one thing I'll do is I'll
transition over to this.
So this is just the GitHub repo.
This is one file, which
is end-to-end use cases
with a number of examples built in
going across examples
requiring fine tuning,
coding, SQL to text, text to SQL,
multimodal type rag use cases,
a whole bunch of variety of example cases
that we developed and we've
put out there as options.
We also have within Llama Cookbooks
a number of the tools that I mentioned.
So I mentioned PropTops.
If you go through Llama Cookbooks,
if you look through
our actual readme here,
a lot of the links to our
tooling and the capabilities
are already built into this.
But then again, this repo has a wealth
of just getting started information.
Now, one thing I should
have linked in here
is AWS also hosts a repo,
which is Llama on AWS.
That one has a bunch
of end-to-end use cases
we've worked with AWS on,
and that also go ahead and
build this type of stuff out.
We actually just worked with them
on a agentic fine-tuning use case
where we just did a roadshow across the US
and we published those.
So if you're looking at building out
coding assistance via agents,
then that's an option as well
that's published on their repo
and was recently published out there.
So I'm gonna go back to our deck here.
And I'm gonna kind of wrap this up here.
So we went over a high level
of considerations you should make.
We didn't go into super deep detail
on actually doing a lot
of that fine-tuning.
One thing we'd love to do is we'd love
to run one post-presentation survey,
like we ran in the beginning.
I'm gonna keep this slide
up here for a minute.
If you can spend a few seconds to do it,
that would be amazing.
All right, and then we have
some next steps for everybody.
So next steps here are,
this presentation was really
covering tools, thoughts,
the way you think about fine-tuning
and setting up for coding.
I also went into exploring a little bit
of the open source
content we have on GitHub,
but that's something I
think is extremely useful
for you to jump into,
especially if you're trying
to solve a problem now
rather than spinning the wheels
and doing it from scratch.
A lot of this has already
been kind of worked on
and pushed into these repos
already for you guys to access.
Obviously, recommendations,
further reading materials,
papers, all of that.
We're always interested in
reading new content as well,
but a lot of that we post
onto the repos as well.
AWS services can help automate
and build out a lot of stuff quickly.
And then again, you can utilize
EKS and all those things
as you look to deploy and scale.
I'm gonna talk about this
slide just really quickly,
'cause I mentioned our tools earlier,
but I didn't get to talk
about them a lot in detail.
I talked about PromptOps.
I wanna talk about DataKit.
DataKit is useful for
your fine-tuning passes
and any of that you wanna do as well.
So basically, it's a tool for
synthetic data generation.
So we built this out
earlier this year as well.
It goes ahead and builds out
and helps you automate that process
when you're looking to develop
a bunch of synthetic data
for, say you're doing eval data sets,
say you're doing training data sets.
The idea is really open.
And there's a lot of examples on our repo
and the Llama on AWS repo,
which have utilized this
to go and train the models.
So I wanted to make sure
I actually talked about that for a second.
So if you haven't seen these tools,
check out the general repos,
go to the Llama webpage.
We have links to everything there as well.
I'll go ahead and end there,
but I'm gonna mention, I'll
hang around for a few minutes.
If you have more specific questions,
I'm happy to chat about them,
but I'll hang out off stage after this.
So thank you guys for attending.
I appreciate it.
(audience applauding)